(drum music)
- [Tushar] We break necks all the time.
It's kind of like the
"deer in the headlights"
look when they see us
because it's unexpected.
(dramatic music)
(drums)
A bunch of brown Indian boys
walking down Fifth Avenue
in New York City in kilts,
you don't see that every day.
(bagpipes music)
My name is Tushar Patel.
I'm a bagpipe player and pipe major for
Shree Muktajeevan Swamibapa Pipe Band-
located at Shree Swaminarayan Temple
in Secaucus, New Jersey.
(soft music)
The Shree Swaminarayan religion
is a more modern religion.
It's a sect of Hinduism
that promotes unity,
non-violence, and peace and well-being
all throughout the world.
(soft music)
Music is definitely the
fundamental of our faith.
Our spiritual leader, Shree
Muktajeevan Swamibapa,
loved music.
He fell in love with the
sound of the bagpipes.
So, he instructed us to
start our own bagpipe band.
(bagpipe music)
No one had any idea how
to play bagpipe music.
- Not so hard; good.
- [Tushar] We found online
videos, internet videos,
we bought a bunch of
intro to bagpipe books.
We didn't know any music, but we knew that
if we worked together, if we were unified,
that we can do anything.
- By the right, quick, march.
(bagpipe music)
- The sound of the
bagpipes; it's very similar
to some instruments
that are found in India.
While we're playing a Scottish bagpipe,
we're still playing Indian
music, as well as American music
and music from all around the world.
(gentle music)
Being here in America, we really wanted
to blend all the cultures
that our band represents.
We like to maintain that traditional
Scottish uniform, but we also like
to blend in the Indian
and American culture.
That uniqueness is what defines our band.
(soft music)
There's really a sense of pride.
We're proud of each other, and
proud of where we've grown.
It's not about only just
playing the bagpipes.
The reason that we play
is to continue spreading
our message of peace
and unity through music.
(gentle music)